the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so let's try to do okay so
let's try to discuss a bit how things
relate to physics okay so there's two
main things I want to discuss one of
them is what curl says about force
fields and in particular
nice consequence of that concerning
gravitational attraction okay so more
about curl first
so we've seen if we have a velocity
field then we've seen that the curl
measures the rotation effects more
precisely curvy measures twice the
angular velocity or maybe I should say
the angular velocity vector because it
also includes the axis of rotation okay
so I should say maybe for the rotation
part of a motion so for example
just to remind you I mean we've seen
this guy a couple of times but if I give
you a uniform rotation motion about the
z-axis so that's a vector field in which
the trajectories I'm going to be circles
centered in the z-axis and our vector
field is just going to be tangent to
each of these circles and if you look at
it from above then you'll have this
rotation vector field that we've seen
many times so typically the velocity
vector from this would be minus y I plus
XJ times maybe the number which
represents how fast we're spinning the
angular velocity in radians per second
and then if you compute the curl of this
you will end up with 2 Omega times K so
now the other kinds of vector fields
we've seen physically are force fields
so the question is what does the curl of
a force field mean what can we say about
that so the interpretation is a little
bit less obvious but let's try to get
some idea of what it might be
okay so I want to remind you that if we
have a solid in a force field we can
measure of a torque of a force we talk
exerted by the force and the solid so
maybe first I should remind you about
what torque is in space so let's say
that I have a piece of solid with a mass
Delta M for example and I have a force
that's being exerted to it so let's say
that maybe my force might be F times
Delta M if you think for example a
gravitational field you know the
gravitational force is actually the
gravitational field times the mass I
mean you can forget the Delta M if you
don't like it and let's say that the
position vector whoops
should be aiming for the origin the
position vector R is here and now let's
say that maybe this guy is at the end of
some arm or some you know metal thing
and I want to hold it in place
so the force is going to exert a torque
relative to the origin that will try to
measure you know how much I am trying to
swing this guy around the origin and
consequently how much effort I have to
exert if I want to actually maintain its
place by just holding it at the end of
the stick here okay so the talk
is now a vector which is just the cross
product of the position vector with the
force and so what the Turk measures
again is the rotation effects of the
force and you know if you remember the
principle that the derivative of
velocity which is acceleration is force
divided by mass then the derivative of
angular velocity should be angular
acceleration which is related to the
torque per unit mass and so it just
remind you if I look at translation
motions you know say I'm just looking at
a point mass so there's no rotation
effect then force divided by mass is
acceleration which is the derivative of
velocity and so what I'm claiming is
that for rotation effects we have a
similar law which maybe you've seen in
801
at least well it's one of the important
things of solid mechanics which is that
the torque of a force divided by the
moment of inertia I'm cheating a little
bit here but if you can see how I'm
cheating then I'm sure you know how to
state it correctly and if you don't see
how I'm cheating then let's just ignore
details is angular acceleration
and angular acceleration is the
derivative of angular velocity okay so
now if I think of curl as an operation
which on the velocity field gives the
angular velocity of its rotation effects
then you see that the curl of an
acceleration field gives me angular
acceleration in the rotation part of the
acceleration effects and therefore the
curl of a force field measures the
torque per unit moment of inertia so it
measures how much torque this force
field exerts on a small test solid
placed in it so if you you know you have
a small solid somewhere the curl will
just measure how much your solid starts
spinning if you leave it in this force
field so in particular a force field
with no curl is a force field that does
not generate any rotation motion so that
means you know if you put an object in
there that's completely immobile and you
leave it in that force field well of
course it might accelerate in some
direction but it won't start spinning
while if you put it in there spinning
already in some direction then well it
should continue to spin in the same way
of course maybe there will be friction
and things like that that will slow it
down but this force field is not
responsible for it
okay so the cool consequence of this if
a first field F derives from the
potential okay so that's what we've seen
about conservative forces so our main
concern so far has been to say if we
have a conservative force field it means
that the work of the force is the change
in the energy and in particular we can't
get energy for free out of it and you
know that the change in potential energy
is going to be related to the change in
kinetic energy so that you know you have
conservation of energy principles well
there's another thing that we know now
because if a force derives from
potential then that means that its curl
is zero that's the criterion we've seen
for force to derive from for vector
field to derive from the potential and
if the curl is zero then it means that
actually this force does not generate
any rotation effects
so for example you know if you try to
understand where does the earth come
from well the earth is spinning on
itself as it goes around the Sun and you
might wonder where does that come from
is that caused by a gravitational
attraction and well the answer is no the
gravitational attraction in itself
cannot cause the earth to start spinning
faster or slower at least if you assume
the earth to be a solid which actually
is false okay but still it doesn't
explain I mean basically the reason why
the earth is spinning is because it was
formed spinning it didn't start spinning
because of gravitational effect and
that's you know a rather deep purely
mathematical consequence of
understanding gravitation in this way so
it's quite spectacular the trace you
know by abstract thinking we got there
socially what's the truth well the truth
is actually the earth the moon and
everything is actually slightly
deformable and so there's deformation
friction effects tidal effect and so on
and these actually cause rotations to
get slightly synchronized with each
other so for example if you want to
explain why the moon is always showing
the same face to the earth so why
rotation of a moon on itself is
synchronized with its revolution around
the earth that is actually explained by
friction effects over time
and the gravitational attraction of the
earth on the moon so there is something
there but if you took perfectly solid
you know perfectly rigid solid bodies
then gravitation would never cause any
rotation effects okay
so of course that tells us that we don't
know how to answer the question of why
is the earth spinning and well that will
be left for another physics class I I
don't have a good answer to that
okay so that was kind of a 2-1 ish let
me now move forward to 802 stuff so I
wanted to tell you things about electric
and magnetic fields and in fact
something that's known as Maxwell's
equations so just a quick poll if you
have been taking first of all how many
of you have been taking a two two or
something like that okay so that's not
very many so for most of you this is a
preview if you've been taking a 2 - have
you seen Maxwell's equations at least
part of them yeah ok so then I'm show in
that case you know better than you what
I'm going to talk about because I'm not
a physicist but just in case
so next words equations govern how
electric and magnetic fields behave how
they are caused by charge electric
charges and the emotions and
particularly explain a lot of things
such as you know how electrical devices
work but also how electromagnetic waves
propagate so in particular that explains
light and in all sorts of waves so
thanks to them that in your cell phone
and your laptop and things like that
work but anyway okay so hopefully most
of you know that the electric field is a
vector field that basically tells you
what kind of force will be exerted on a
charged particle that you put in it so
if you have a particle carrying an
electric charge then
this vector field will tell you
basically there will be an electric
force which is the charge times e that
will be exerted on that particle and
that's what responsible for example for
the flow of electrons when you have a
voltage difference because classically
this guy is actually the gradient of a
potential and that Bolton that potential
is just electric voltage the magnetic
field is a little bit harder to think
about if you've never seen it in physics
but you know it's what's causing for
example magnets to work and well it
basically it's a force that's also
expressed in terms of a vector field
usually called B some people call it H
but I'm going to use B and that first
tends to cause if you have a moving
charged particle then that will cause it
to deflect its trajectory and start
rotating in the magnetic field so what
it does is not quite as easy as what the
electric field does just to give you
formulas the force because the electric
field is the charge times the electric
field and the first caused by the
magnetic field is well I always I'm
never sure about the sine is at the
correct sign good okay so now the
question is we need to understand how
these fields themselves are caused by
the bank by the charged particles that
are placed in them and so there's
various laws in there that explain
what's going on so let me focus today on
the electric field so
Maxwell's equations actually tell you
about div and curl of these fields so
let's look at div and curl of the
electric field so the first equation is
called the Gauss Coulomb now and it says
that the divergence of the electric
field is equal to so this is just a
physical constant what it's equal to
depends on what units you are using and
this guy whoa
well it's not the same as in spherical
coordinates because physicists somehow
patented by use of that letter first
it's the actually the electric charge
density so it's the amount of electric
charge per unit volume so what it tells
you what this tells you is that
divergence of E is caused by the
presence of electric charge in
particular if you have an empty region
of space or region where nothing has
electrical charge then E has trip as
divergence equal to zero so now that
looks like a very abstract strange
equation I mean actually it's a partial
differential equation satisfied by the
electric field E and that's not very
intuitive in any way ok so what's
actually more intuitive is what we get
if we apply the divergence theorem to
this equate ok so if I think now about
any closed surface ok and I want to
think about the flux of the electric
field out of that surface
so we haven't really thought about what
the flux of a force field does and I
don't want to get into that because
there's no very easy and so in general
but I'm going to explain soon how this
can be useful sometimes but so let's say
that we want to find the flux of the
electric field out of a closed surface
then by the divergence theorem that's
equal to the triple integral over the
region inside of DV DV which is by the
equation one of our epsilon zero that's
this constant times the triple integral
of Rho DV but now if I integrate the
charge density over the entire region
then what I will get is actually the
total amount of electric charge inside
the region okay so that's the electric
charge in D so this one tells us in a
more concrete way how electric charge is
placed in here influence the electric
field around them in particular one
application of that is if you want to
study capacitors so capacitors are these
things that store energy by basically
you have two plates one that contains
positive charge we have a negative
charge and then you have a voltage
between these plates and that can act
basically they can provide electrical
energy to power maybe an electrical
circuit and so it's kind of it's not
really a bad way because it doesn't
store energy in large enough amounts for
that but for example that's why you know
when you switch your favorite gadget or
if it doesn't actually go up immediately
but somehow you see things dimming
progressively there's a capacitor in
there so if you want to understand how
the voltage and recharge relate to each
other
where the voltage is obtained by
integrating the electric field from one
plate to the other plate and the force
so if the charges in the plates are what
causes the electric field between the
plate
so that's how you can get the relation
between voltage and charge in these guys
that's an example of application of that
okay now of course if you haven't seen
any of this then maybe it's a little bit
esoteric but that will tell you you know
part of what you will see in 802 okay
questions I see some confused faces okay
well don't worry it will make sense
someday so the next one I want to tell
you about is Faraday's law so in case
you're confused by the way if Maxwell's
equations so there's four equations in
the set of Maxwell's equations and most
of them don't carry Maxwell's name I
mean that's a quirky feature of them but
so that one tells you about the curl of
the electric field so now depending on
your knowledge you might start telling
me well the curl of the electric field
has to be zero because it's derived it
derives from actually it's the gradient
of the electric potential I told you
this stuff about voltage
well that doesn't account for the fact
that sometimes you can create voltage
out of nowhere using magnetic fields and
in fact you have a failure of
constitutive 'ti of the electric force
if you have a magnetic field so what
this one says is actually the curl of e
is not zero but rather it's the
derivative of the magnetic field with
respect to time okay so more precisely
it tells you that what you might have
learned about electric fields deriving
from electric potential becomes false if
you have a variable magnetic field and
just to tell you you know that's again a
strange partial differential equation
relating these two vector fields so
to make sense of it one should use
Stokes theorem okay so if we apply
Stokes theorem to compute the work done
by the electric field around a closed
curve so that means you know you have a
wire in there and you want to find the
voltage along the wire so now there's a
strange thing because classically you
would say well if I just have a wire
with nothing in it there's no voltage on
it well small change in plans
if you actually have a vying elect a
varying magnetic field that passes
through that wire then that will
actually generate voltage in it and
that's how a transformer works so it
transformer you know when you plug your
laptop into the wall socket you don't
actually feed it directly 110 volts or
hundred twenty volts or whatever there's
a transformer in there and where the
transformer does is it takes some input
voltage and it passes that for basically
a loop of wire okay not much seems to be
happening but now you have another loop
of wire that is intertwined with it and
somehow the magnetic field generated by
so it has to be alternating current the
alternating current varies over time in
the first wire that generates a magnetic
field that varies over time so that
causes DB by DT and that causes curl of
the electric field and the curl of the
electric field will generate voltage
between these two gates and that's how
the transformer works it uses Stokes
theorem okay so more precisely how do we
find the voltage between these two
points well let's close the loop and
let's try to figure out the voltage
inside this loop so to find the voltage
along a closed curve placed in a varying
magnetic field so we have to do the line
integral along a closed curve of the
electric field and you could think of
this as the voltage generated in this
circuit that will be the flux
fold this surface bounded by the curve
of curl e dot DS that's what Stokes
theorem says and now if you combine with
Faraday's law you end up with the flux
for s of minus DB DT and of course you
could take if your loop doesn't move
over time so I mean actually there's
there's a different story if you start
somehow taking your wire and somehow
moving it inside the field but if you
don't do that if it's the field that's
moving then you just can take the D by
DT outside but let's not bother ok so
again what this equation tells you is
that if magnetic field changes over time
then it creates just out of nowhere an
electric field and that electric field
can be used to power things so
I don't really claim that I've given you
enough details to understand how they
work but basically these equations are
at the heart of understanding how things
like capacitors and transformers work
and they also explain a lot of other
things but I will leave that to your
physics teachers just for completeness
let me just give you the last two
equations in that I'm not even going to
try to explain them too much so one of
them says that the divergence of the
magnetic field is zero which somehow is
fortunate because otherwise you would
run into trouble trying to understand
surface independence when you apply
Stokes theorem in here and the last one
tells you how the curl of the magnetic
field is caused by motion of charged
particles so in fact say that the curl
of J so the curl of B is given by this
kind of formula where J is what's called
the vector current density so it
measures the flow of electrically
charged particles okay so you get this
guy when you start taking charged
particles like electrons maybe and
moving them around and of course that's
actually part of how transformers work
because I've told you you know running
the AC for the first loop generates a
magnetic field well how does it do that
it's thanks to this equation if you have
a current passing in the loop that
causes a magnetic field and in turn for
the other equation that causes an
electric field which in terms causes a
current so it's all somehow intertwined
in a very intricate way and it's going
to remarkable how well that works in
practice
okay so
I think that's basically all I wanted to
say about a tutu I don't want to you
know put your physics teachers out of a
job so if you haven't seen any of this
before I understand that this is
probably not detailed enough to be
really understandable but hopefully it
makes you it will make you a bit curious
about that and prompt you to you know
take that class someday and maybe even
remember how it relates to 1802